let me ask you kind of a big
philosophical question about Ai and and
the threat of it uh let's look like uh
at the threat side so folks like Elias
yadkowski worry that AI might
kill all of us
do you worry about that range of
possibilities where artificial
intelligence systems
in a variety of ways might uh destroy
human civilization
I talk a lot about it about the dangers
of AI I sometimes get into trouble
because I depict these scenarios of how
AI becoming very dangerous and then
people say that I'm encouraging these
scenarios but I'm I'm you know I'm
talking about it as a warning I'm not so
terrified of the simplistic idea again
the Terminator scenario of robot running
in the street shooting everybody
I'm more worried about AI accumulating
more and more power and basically taking
over Society based taking over our lives
taking power away from us until we don't
understand what is happening and we lose
control of our lives and of the future
the two most important things to realize
about AI you know so many things are
being said now about AI but I think
there are two things that every person
should know about AI
first is that AI is the First Tool in
history that can make decisions by
itself
all previous Tools in history couldn't
make decisions this is why they
empowered us you invent a knife you
invent an atom bomb the atom bomb cannot
decide to start a war cannot decide
which city to own
AI can make decisions by itself
an autonomous weapon systems can decide
by themselves who to kill who to bomb
the second thing is that AI is the First
Tool in history that can create new
ideas by itself
the printing press could print our ideas
but could not create new ideas AI can
create new ideas entirely by itself
this is unprecedented therefore it is
the first technology in history that
instead of giving power to humans it
takes power away from us
and the danger is that if it will
increasingly take more and more power
from us
until we are left helpless and clueless
about what is happening in the world and
this is already beginning to happen in
an accelerated uh Pace more and more
decisions about our lives whether to
give us a loan whether to give us a
mortgage whether to give us a job or
taking by Ai and more and more of the
ideas of the images of the stories that
surround us and shape our our minds our
world our produced or created by AI not
by human beings if you can just Linger
on that what is the danger of that that
more and more of the creative
side
is done by AI the idea generation
is it that we become stale in our
thinking is that that idea generation is
so fundamental to like the
evolution of humanity but we can't
resist the idea is to to resist an idea
you need to have some some vision of of
the creative process yeah now this is a
very old fear
um you go back to Plato's Cave
some of this idea that people are
sitting chained in a cave and seeing
shadows on a screen on a wall and
thinking this is reality
you go back to to the cart and he has
this thought experiment of the of the
demon and the card asks himself how do I
know that any of this is real maybe
there is a demon who is creating all of
this and is basically enslaving Me by
surrounding me with these Illusions you
go back to Buddha it's the same question
what if we are living in a world of
Illusions and because we have been
living in it throughout our lives all
our ideas or our desires how we
understand ourselves this is all the
product of the same illusions
and this was a big philosophical
question for thousands of years now it's
becoming a practical question of
engineering because previously all the
ideas as far as we know maybe we are
living inside a computer simulation or
for intelligent Rats from the planet
Zircon if that's the case we don't know
about it but taking what we do know
about human history until now all the
again stories images paintings songs
operas theater everything we've
encountered and shaped our minds was
created by humans
now increasingly we live in a world
where the more and more of these
cultural artifacts will be coming from
an alien intelligence
very quickly we might reach a point when
most
of the story stories images songs TV
shows whatever are created by an alien
intelligence
and
um if we now find ourselves inside this
kind of world of illusions
created by an alien intelligence that we
don't understand but it understands us
this is a kind of you know spiritual
enslavement that we won't be able to
break out of because it understands us
it understands how to manipulate us but
we don't understand
what is behind this screen of stories
and images and and songs
so if there's a set of AI systems that
are operating in the space of ideas
they're far superior to ours and we're
not almost able to it's it's opaque to
us we're not able to see through how
does that change the um
the pursuit of happiness
the human pursuit of happiness life
where do we get joy
if there were surrounded by AI systems
that are doing most of the cool things
humans do much better than us you know
some of the things it's okay that the
AIS would do them many human tasks and
jobs
um you know it's it's the drudgery they
are not fun they are not developing I
will ask emotionally or spiritually it's
fine if the robots take over
I don't know I think about the people in
supermarkets or grocery stores that
spend hours every day just you know
passing uh items and and then charging
you the money I mean if this can be
automated wonderful we need to make sure
that these people uh then have better
jobs uh uh better means of supporting
themselves and developing their social
abilities their spiritual abilities uh
and and that that's the that's the ideal
world that AI can create
that it takes away from us the things
that uh uh it's better if we don't do
them
and allows us to focus on the most
important things and the deepest aspects
of of our nature of our potential
if we give AI Control of the sphere of
ideas at this stage I think it's very
very dangerous because it doesn't
understand us and
AI at present is mostly digesting the
products of human culture
everything we've produced over thousands
of years it eats all of these cultural
products digests it and starts producing
its own new stuff
but we still still haven't figured out
ourselves in our bodies our brains our
minds our psychology
um so an AI based on our float
understanding of ourselves is a very
dangerous thing
I think that we need first of all to
keep developing ourselves
if if for every dollar and every minute
that we spend on developing AI
artificial intelligence we spend another
dollar and another minute in developing
human consciousness the human mind will
be okay
the danger is that we spend all our
effort on developing an AI at the time
that we don't understand ourselves
and then letting the AI take over that's
that's a road to a human catastrophe
does this surprise you how well large
language models work I mean has it
modified your understanding of the
nature of intelligence yes I mean you
know I've been writing about AI for
I know like eight years now
and engage with all these predictions
and speculations and when it actually
came it was much faster and more
powerful than I thought it would be
um I didn't think that we would have in
2023 and AI that can hold the
conversation that you can't know if it's
a human being or an AI that can write
beautiful texts in telling I mean I I
read the texts written by AI
and the thing that strikes me most is
the coherence
you know people think oh it's nothing
they just takes ideas from here and
their words for me and and putting no
it's so current I mean you read in not
sentences you read paragraphs you read
entire texts and there is logic that
there is the structure not only go here
and it's convincing yes and the
beautiful thing about it that has to do
with your work it doesn't have to be
true
gets facts wrong but it still is
convincing
and it is both scary and beautiful yeah
that our brains love language so much
that we don't
need the facts to be correct we just
need it to be a beautiful story yeah and
that's been the secret of politics and
religion for thousands of years and now
it's coming with AI so you as a person
who has written some of the most
impactful words ever written in your
books uh how does that make you feel
that you might be one of the last
effective human writers that's a good
question
first of all do you think that's
possible I think it is possible
um I I've seen a lot of examples of AI
being told right like you will know
Harare and what it produces has it ever
done better than you think you could
have written yourself
I mean on the level of content of ideas
no there are things I say I would I
would never say that
but when it comes to the you know I mean
there is again the coherence and the
quality of writing is such
that I say it's it's unbelievable how
good it is
and who knows in 10 years in 20 years
maybe it can do better even on in
according to certain measures of on the
level of of content
so that people would be able to do like
a style transfer to uh in the style of
Yvonne or Harare right anything right
why I should have ice cream tonight
and and make it convincing I don't know
if I have anything convincing to say
about this I think you'll be surprised I
think you'd be surprised they could be
an evolutionary biology explanation for
why ice cream is good for you yeah so I
mean uh
I mean that changes the nature of
writing ultimately I I think it it goes
back
um
much of of my writing is suspicious of
itself I write stories about the danger
of stories I write about intelligence
but highlighting the dangers of
intelligence ultimately I don't think
that in terms of power
human power comes from intelligence and
from stories but I think that the
deepest and best qualities of humans are
not
intelligence and not storytelling and
not power
again with all our power with all our
cooperation with our intelligence we are
on the verge of destroying ourselves and
destroying much of the ecosystem
our best qualities are not there
our best qualities are non-verbal again
they come from things like compassion
from introspection and introspection for
my experience is not variable if you try
to understand yourself with words you
will never succeed there is a a place
where you need the words
but the deepest insights they don't come
from words
and you can't write about it that that's
second it goes back to to Wittgenstein
to Buddha to so many of these sages
before that uh this these are the things
we are silent about
yeah but eventually you have to project
it as a writer you have to
do the silent introspection but project
it onto a page yes but you still have to
warn people you will never find the
deepest truth in a book you will never
find it in words
uh you can only find it in I think in
direct experience which is non-verbal
which is pretty verbal
in the Silence of your own mind yes
somewhere in there